what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so to help you on your
journey today I'm going to talk about
the seven ways to make your ecommerce
business wildly successful so this is a
topic I get asked a lot by entrepreneurs
they have an e-commerce store they want
to ramp up their business they want to
get more attention they want to drive
more sales but it's not working for them
and so today I'm going to share with you
seven different ways on how to make your
e-commerce business wildly successful
[Music]
way number one is you actually have to
believe in your product this might sound
crazy but a lot of the people who set up
ecommerce stores never actually use
their products that they're selling it
boggles my mind whenever I'm working
with a company that I want to represent
or they want me to help pitch or promote
their product I always have to use it
first I have to feel a personal
connection to the thing that I'm selling
so as an example with sage I signed a
three-year deal with sage and Stephen
Kelly he's been on the channel every
month talking about entrepreneurship I
actually use sage software in my company
it's what I use to grow my business
that's how I run my accounting if you
wanted to sit down and open up your sage
accounting software I'd be able to walk
through how to use it because I use it
myself
I hate recommending products or I hate
working with companies when I haven't
actually used a thing that I'm saying is
a good thing and so I think that happens
way too often on ecommerce shops you're
promoting something because you think
there's an opportunity you think there's
a market for but you haven't actually
used it and so that always has to be the
starting point you have to believe in
the product or service that you are
selling
[Music]
way number two is make sure there's
demand a lot of times people start off
ecommerce shops and there is no actual
demand for the product and so you're
building up a community you're building
up an audience maybe you're active on
social media you're creating YouTube
videos you're on snapchat Instagram
Facebook you're creating content and
then you want to try to sell something
but you haven't actually received any
kind of demand for people so it makes it
really hard to identify where the market
opportunity is the best way to be able
to identify the products is from people
who are in the industry and wanting to
have a solution to a problem that they
have sort of example if I'm making a new
product I would test it out on my
youtube channel I would create a video
talking about this new thing that I had
a new idea that I wanted to create and
see what the feedback was what you want
before starting that business is to get
market feedback customers or potential
customers ideal customers saying yes we
need this because what happens is so
often we go down this rabbit hole we
spend so much time working on this
product and researching the best
companies to buy from and takes tons of
time and tons of energy and you're
investing dollars and resources to make
it happen only to find out that nobody
actually wants this thing and you sell
five versions of it or five copies of it
or five units it's a big waste of time
and so you always want to start with the
market first find the thing that you
believe in and that there's a market
that's how you start to win something
you passionately believe in that works
and there is a demand for
[Music]
way number three is get distribution now
that you have a product you know this
demand for it is something that you are
using and you believe in you need to
think how am I going to get the word out
about it because an ecommerce store is
fairly easy to set up there's not a ton
of technology that you need to have an
e-commerce shop you need to figure out
how do I get my product in front of a
whole bunch of people and the fastest
way to do it the fastest way to build
your business is to find people who are
already selling to your target audience
and find some way to be able to work
together so an example if you're trying
to sell the entrepreneurs you might want
to talk to me if I love your product if
I use your app if I'm using your service
then I'm more likely to want to tell the
people in my community about it and so
there's a number of products that I'm
testing out right now there's a social
media management product that I'm
looking at there's a guy who came by
today he wanted to pitch me on his
language translation and dubbing service
to take my YouTube channel and put it
into Spanish in different markets so
what he's doing he's gonna take ten of
my videos he's gonna dub them into
Spanish and we're gonna see how it goes
and if it works then I'm gonna tell my
friends about it I'm gonna use it I'm
gonna pay him he's gonna make money off
of me and I'm gonna tell my YouTube
buddies about it as well he was a great
service and so what you wanted to do was
find a distribution who is the person
that if they said this is great they can
open up the floodgates for you so
instead of trying to hit people one one
one at a time you're talking to an
influencer who can get you mass
distribution and you're hitting hundreds
thousands or hundred thousand people at
the same time wing number four is have
beautiful pictures it's just so
surprising how many e-commerce shops
when they're selling their products
don't have beautiful pictures it's a
great way to be able to stand out and
get your products or services notice
because the picture is visually stunning
if you look at eBay as an example people
who are selling their products on eBay
most people don't take the time to
actually take a fantastic picture and
the picture will sell it if you're
scrolling through a list of products a
beautiful looking picture it will make a
huge difference to getting people to
click on it and learn more about the
products and so you want to make sure
that you're investing time in to taking
beautiful pictures if you can afford to
bring somebody on to do that or you're
taking on an intern who loves
photography or it's just a skill set
that you want to develop yourself make
sure that every single product first of
all has a picture because a lot of
ecommerce store
they don't even have a picture you need
a product picture and then make sure
that it's a beautiful one we number five
is write detailed descriptions so
alongside a picture you want to make
sure that there's a great detailed
description of the product so many
e-commerce stores have product pages
that really suck it's one paragraph or a
couple lines that's not enough to
convince somebody to want to make that
purchase and so you really want to tell
the story ideally a personal story right
back to point number one you believe in
this product tell me your story tell me
why you love this thing tell me why it's
so great and you've achieved personal
benefit from using it put that story in
there I want to understand what the
benefits are I want to understand what
the potential side effects are I want to
say and how much it's gonna cost me I
want to say in your personal store
behind it and you're optimizing
everything from a usability and reader
perspective as well as SEO traffic a lot
of e-commerce stores suck on SEO because
their product descriptions are really
really really poor so invest the time in
photography invest the time into making
great products scriptures with your own
personal story and that might mean that
you drop down to a hundred products
instead of ten thousand but you're
really picking the ones that you care
about weight number five is get their
emails one of the biggest mistakes that
ecommerce stores make is they expect
someone to buy their product right away
this is the equivalent of getting
married on your first date people don't
get married on the first date
usually it sometimes happens but usually
it's not how it works you come back and
so my goal if somebody's coming to an
e-commerce shop is to get somebody to
take one extra step I want to give them
some kind of bonus and get them on my
email list so that I have a way to
follow up with them if you are expecting
somebody to land on your website buy the
product immediately that will be a
certain percentage but you're leaving a
ton of money on the table what you want
to do is date before getting married
have them come to your website have
beautiful pictures great description
your story in there have a newsletter
with a bonus offer for people to be able
to get some extra value learning from
you and then you have permission to
market to them you're setting up an
email campaign follow-up series where
you're providing value on a regular
basis and including products that would
be relevant to them if you have that
extra bit in between the visit to the
sale you're
like to convert sales on an ongoing
basis because you've collected their
email address as opposed to just hoping
that they think of you all the time and
come back and buy from your website and
we number seven is get the tech right
there's a lot that you can learn and I'm
not the best guy to talk about the tech
side of ecommerce but things like your
low time things like your shopping cart
optimization reducing the number of
steps that people have to take from
interest to to purchase all the things
that you need to get right from a
technical perspective just do your
research if this is going to be your
business you want to be an e-commerce
retailer this is how you're going to
make your money then you need to know
the best tech you don't have to know how
it all works
you have to know the details of how to
code something on the back end but you
need to pick the best technology that's
going to help you accomplish your goals
so those are my seven ways on how to
have wild success as an ecommerce store
I love to know from you which one was
your favorite which one is most
applicable that you're going to work on
in your business today did I miss an 8 9
10 that you want to add to the list
leave your thoughts down the comments
below I look forward to hearing from you
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details